[Music]
hey there guys it's dalabo for the iron
Lords podcast coming at you here was a
little first impressions video for the
Raven remastered we've got quite a few
things to say about this game so let's
go ahead and get right into it
The Raven legacy of a master thief was
originally released in 2013 this
remaster developed by King art games and
published by THQ Nordic aims to give us
that game yet again but better looking
in this point and click adventure game
you follow constable Zelda on his quest
to capture the Raven who's been stealing
various things like jewels and such
there are several situations which you
have to make like dialogue choices so
not that I found that any of those
actually impact anything I think it's
just for a flavor text but yeah you do
get to make some dialogue choices here
and there all in all you're basically
like a detective who's not really a
detective yet but kinda wants to be so
keep that in mind first up are the
graphics the art style is actually
rather Pleasant as someone who is pretty
used to the tell-tale games it's good to
see another art style personally I mean
I thought that life is strange in that
kind of art so that was a huge breath of
fresh air so it's good to see them going
something with something different even
though it's from 2013 but you guys when
you remove the game from Doc mode and
playing handle mode it actually does it
looks fine it there's nothing blaringly
wrong with it um nothing feels like it's
jagged or anything like that it's just a
few less textures that kind of thing but
you know it still looks really good the
only thing that really bothered me was
the changes in Mike faces how some faces
were definitely based in reality while
others were more cartoony the cartoony
ones kind of sort of took me out of it
just a little bit but that's just like a
personal gripe when looking at it
compared to the original release yes
there are definite improvements but
nothing that makes the game like really
pop out as a remaster he just it's it's
definitely just a cleanup job next up is
the gameplay now the game has you take
control of constable zelner the first
mission has you trying to do things like
locating a stolen purse and break
to a room now in order to do any of
those things you have to talk to
everyone it's really weird how much
dialogues in this title like I never
thought in this type of game too much
dialogue would ever be a thing but it
would create such a problem with pacing
like a huge problem facing but I'll get
to that in just a second like a lot of
the dialogue just seems like it's there
for padding the extra conversations
wouldn't be such a big deal if the main
character weren't such a bore like while
he is clever I can't help but feel like
I'd be more invested in him if you know
he were more unique he just he just
isn't asked with a detective aspect of a
certain items that you need to obtain
are pretty straightforward right away I
got a tip from the game that said to
talk to everyone if I got stuck and you
know that actually came in handy however
it was very annoying you know having a
lack of instruction when it came to
using the items you see certain items
that you pick up can be combined with
other items that you have war items in
the environment one such task has you
taking away a toy gun from a kid and the
sleigh that kid is mad at you and will
help you under question a more so in
order to you know gain back his trust or
whatever you have to give him candy it
makes sense it's a little creepy but it
makes sense but another situation has
you having to make a fingerprint powder
out of a pencil and scissors because to
shave the pencil with the scissors in
order to get the graphite so that you
can dust for fingerprints and I'm not
gonna lie to you that one took me a
while to figure out now that I'm suppose
to be like a makeshift detective or
whatever but how am I supposed to know
that like I understand what my character
would know that but me myself why would
I know that I will however say that the
game did give me some aha moments that's
one of the great things I love about
puzzle ish games is when when you solve
a puzzle by yourself and you can tell
that it was you know a rather tricky one
you know that sense of accomplishment
does really feel good and it is
definitely there within the game so back
to the pacing while the plot within the
game can definitely be interesting at
times in fact they start the game off
with an explosion in a museum you know
and a robber getting away with a jewel
that's cool you know that that really
hooks you into the plot but once you're
actually able to play the game it's such
a slow
I cannot emphasize this enough this game
is not for everyone if you do not have
patience for this kind of game in which
the narrative is explained very slowly
over the course of the game like we're
gathering clues makes you invested into
certain characters and things like that
this game will not appeal to you in any
way shape or form
what's more the game has very egregious
load times the load times in this game
are just it's out of this world
sometimes like there are very small
rooms within this train that you're on
and so you're going between certain
sections of the Train like between
certain cars means that you have to load
the other cars and in the game like this
long load times can be very annoying and
actually kind of take you out of it
because you'll need something in the
back car of the Train and then you'll
have to go all the way back to the front
car for something else and in between
those two spots there's like three
loading screens or something like that
there's two or three something like that
and but either way that's like it gets
really frustrating especially when you
realize that you forgot something in a
previous car you can get you can get
pretty bad but all of that said it still
is a very fun game in regards to its
narrative once you do get to the the
solid points of the narrative it is very
interesting I think that it does have a
lot of pull what I would say is that you
are if you are having a hard time with
any particular part of the game just go
ahead and look up and walk through
because certain things you're not gonna
get and I I would really hate for anyone
to lose out on such a good story just
because they couldn't find something or
something like that it's definitely just
one of those games I'd like to extend a
huge thank you to King art games for
providing us with this code means a lot
it was an awesome awesome time playing
this game and just really getting my
detective on you know and as always you
can catch the iron Lords podcast here
every Sunday it's good time it's every
time you should have to check out
there's some funny people on there
talking about games and such get you
some of that and stay perfect
[Music]
you
[Music]